we're going to also say since we're from
new york we're going to call her
although it's spelt houston we're going
to call her whitney houston street
whitney house
whitney house whitney houston houston
started her modeling career when she was
16.
here's the difference between america
and canada our most favorite
our most famous crack addict is whitney
houston
yes one of the greatest cigarettes to
ever grace
the earth in all of history right and
canada's most famous crack user
is uh toronto mayor rob ford yeah
and that and that should go more to tell
you that because we're just better at
everything even our crack is better
a lot of emotional stress yeah okay
my eating habits were awful whitney
dying
crack rehab exactly first of all let's
get one thing
straight exactly
i make too much money to every single
crack let's get that straight
okay exactly crack his wax so i still to
this day and like do not really whack
the girl is an amazing [ __ ] singer um
same with amy winehouse the voices are
beautiful but it just seems like yeah a
lot of that
talent up there it just musically i mean
they just get in drugs and alcohol i
think it's a lot of the lifestyle
yeah is a big part of it i think and i
think mate do you think maybe just
because this is a cosmic joke this life
that when you're given that much of a
talent there's also an equally
an equal but opposite blind spot and
that blind spot was for some good
ol big fat jailhouse
former boy band good old dick
dick bobby brown bobby brown's dick must
have been
[ __ ] stupid bobby brown famous yeah
he's dancing man
do wow the 80s were wild where you could
just wear a space suit you're just good
and a flat top cause i mean you're
everyone's outfit in the 80s when they
were on
stage looked like they were in spacex
and they were going to mars yeah they
were going to mars they yeah
they're all it's all elon musk stuff
never to walk
in anyone's shadow if i
fail if i succeed at least i'll
live without belief we can't say
god did not bless us with that he didn't
bless us with that and are we going to
get limited or no ants because we sang a
cover oh because they're going to
listen to it they won't even recognize
that it was her song because we sounded
so bad i
can imagine being on that set and just
getting to see the magic work and
imagine just getting able to being able
to kiss kevin costner in the scene
i mean that's the thing i mean kevin
costner he was in dances with wolves
dolly parton 1970s dolly parton i first
girl i ever jerked off to
she had she was the original like big
natty
big natty celebrity yeah those were
natties right yeah
oh here's a fun fact saddam hussein
loved whitney houston's rendition
uh so much that he used it in arabic
version of i will always love you as his
re-election campaign theme
so he used i will always love you in
arabic as his re-election campaign thief
saddam hussein
right everyone like i agree with you
people aren't going to live forever
anyway
right it's like if you want to do some
drugs and and go out of 48
that's your business right she gave the
world her gift like you said
what else do you want what else do you
want this [ __ ] lady to do yeah then
auto tune came out and all these [ __ ]
ai robots you know copying her voice
people copyrighted her style
what else do you want to do i mean you
gave us your angelic gorgeous beautiful
voice
you know i have t-shirts i'll get a
whitney houston tattoo i don't give a
[ __ ]
it's like if you wanted a bathtub before
50 i mean most of them don't make it you
know prince michael jackson whitney it's
like
what it's like it's like seeing a tall
older person
you know if you're you know it doesn't
happen you don't really see
rock stars living into their 70s radius
there's a few but most of them go out
early and it's sad but it's just kind of
par for the course i think you know i
mean if you're gonna die in a bathtub
you want to
die in a first-rate bathtub i mean yes
dying in the beverly hills hotel bathtub
beats the [ __ ] out of dying in a ramada
inn bathtub in uniontown pennsylvania
yeah
which is how i'm going to die which is
how you're going to die
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it and go to
patreon.comridgeboys where things get
really wild